so the most overpriced item in all of
the tech world right now is
the Intel Mac Pro so it's going to
hopefully be replaced pretty soon but as
of right now first of all Apple does a
thing where they never really lower the
prices of anything as it gets older so
they're still selling it for the full
price that it launched at in 2019 which
starts at six grand and can be specked
up to over 52 000 but then number two
it's being out benchmarked right now by
a literal Mac Mini okay watch my review
apple silicons and wonders for the new
Max and the 1300 M2 Mac Mini is
literally more powerful in CPU and GPU
than the base Mac Pro but on top of all
of that if you go to Google and type in
apple trade-in it takes you to their
trading calculator and if you put in the
serial number and specs with a perfect
condition maxed out Mac Pro that you
could have bought yesterday that they're
selling right now for 50 Grand they will
offer you a borderline insulting 970
dollars that's less than an iPhone 14
pro so this is pretty clearly at the top
of the list now the worst deal in Tech
hands down that's not even mentioning
the 700 Wheels with no bricks